[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
johanna bereits guten abend und herzlich
willkommen mit dabei für den sport
norbert lehmann
und das sind die wichtigsten themen
heute schwere explosionen leverkusen ein
mensch stirbt vier weitere werden
vermisst in einem der größten
chemieparks in europa debatte über
verschärfungen für reiserückkehrer der
gesundheitsminister will die testpflicht
deutlich ausweiten erste goldmedaille
für deutschland sie kann nur die
amerikaner 5 und die dressur equipe der
frauen holen die ersehnten die explosion
in einem chemiewerk in leverkusen an
diesem morgen ist gewaltig mindestens
ein mitarbeiter kommt ums leben 31
werden verletzt einige davon schwer
nach vier menschen wird weiter gesucht
der unfall passiert in einer
müllverbrennungsanlage beim
stadtteilbüro überstunden sieht man eine
riesige rauchwolke
alle die in einem umkreis von mehreren
kilometern wohnen werden aufgefordert
fenster und türen zu schließen
wichtige autobahn müssen stundenlang
gesperrt werden der katastrophenschutz
spricht von einer extremen gefahr
gabriele hahn hält mit den einzelheiten
große rauchschwaden über der stadt nach
der explosion im leverkusener chemiepark
im bereich einer sonder
müllverbrennungsanlage detoniert gegen
halb zehn ein tank und gerät in brand
feuerwehren aus der ganzen region reisen
an und sperren das areal großräumig ab
31 personen sind verletzt vier menschen
werden vermisst der leverkusener
oberbürgermeister ist bei der
improvisierten pressekonferenz sichtlich
berührt es gibt einen toten
die gedanken der stadt leverkusen sind
bei der familie des getöteten
mitarbeiter
und natürlich viel kraft für die
verletzten zwei fällt schwer verletzten
mitarbeiterin mitarbeiter heute morgen
dann bisher zu schaden gekommen sind
der tank war mit lösungsmitteln gefüllt
ob hier auch giftige substanzen
freigesetzt wurden lässt sich noch nicht
beantworten
anwohner sind besorgt
klar macht sich schon gedanken aber ich
weiß jetzt nicht was genau drin war so
genau kommt muss ja noch nicht direkt
feststellen ja das schlimmste war dass
auch über die über radio soweit immer
die meldung kam ist nicht klar ob der
giftstoffe in der wolke sind
das feuer ist mittlerweile gelöscht die
ursachensuche wird noch tage dauern
der sogenannte chempark ist einer der
größten chemie parkanlagen europas 70
firmen sind hier angesiedelt viele von
ihnen verwenden brennbare chemikalien
eine schwere stunde für den
chemiestandort deutschland und vor ort
ist für uns heiko rahms heiko wie konnte
es zu diesem unfall kommen
dazu kann man ganz genau im moment noch
nichts sagen ich stehe hier einige
hundert meter vom chempark entfernt und
dort hinten sind zurzeit die
rettungskräfte damit beschäftigt die
vier vermissten arbeiter zu finden das
ist keine einfache suche denn die
explosion war so gewaltig dass das
firmengelände verwüstet wurde
und jetzt wirklich ganz genau nach
geguckt werden muss wo sich was befindet
das ist hier auch ein sehr sensibler ort
denn dieser chempark befindet sich in
unmittelbarer nähe zu einer der grössten
giftmülldeponien in europa und die
behörden schauen hier ganz ganz genau
hin was ihr genau vor sich geht erst
wenn die suche nach den arbeitern
abgeschlossen ist dann erst können die
experten auf das gelände und mit der
suche nach einer möglichen
unglücksursache beginnen aber bis da
erste ergebnisse vorliegen das kann noch
eine ganze zeit lang dauern
vielen dank heiko rams schauen wir jetzt
auf die pandemie
es sind gerade sommerferien viele sind
weggefahren wenn es nach
bundesgesundheitsminister sparen geht
sollen sich alle testen lassen müssen
die wieder nach deutschland einreisen
außer geimpfte wie das gehen kann wird
gerade geprüft
unabhängig davon ändert sich schon heute
etwas für alle die in spanien oder den
niederlanden urlaub machen
denn in beiden ländern steigt die zahl
der neu infektionen rasant im sieben
tage schnitt auf 2 135 bzw auf 383 sie
gelten daher nun als hoch incidents
gebiete für rückreisen da heißt dass
zehn tage quarantäne
frey testen geht nach frühestens fünf
tagen ausgenommen nur geimpfte und
genesene jan hofer ferienflieger aus
hoch inzidenz gebieten wie spanien
landen heute mittag am flughafen
köln/bonn nur geimpft und genesene
müssen nicht in quarantäne alle anderen
auch kinder schon das kontrolliert hier
die bundespolizei allerdings nur
stichprobenartig sonst nur in corona tis
vorzeigen und passend zum 60
außerdem haben wir eine sms bekommen
dass wir die garantie regeln und die ja
und die sonstigen verordnungen beachten
seien strenger kontrollieren wäre
vielleicht nicht schlecht wie kann man
so sagen
immerhin an deutschen flughäfen gibt es
kontrollen reisende die mit dem auto
unterwegs sind zum beispiel aus hoch
inzidenz gebieten wie den niederlanden
werden so gut wie gar nicht kontrolliert
wer beispielsweise ungeimpfte wie aus
den niederlanden kommen wirklich in
quarantäne gehen oder nicht vor allem
eine frage der eigenen verantwortung
da muss man halt im moment darauf
vertrauen dass jeder so ehrlich ist und
auch alles angibt was anzugeben ist und
sich dann notfalls natürlich auch selbst
in die quarantäne blieb denn auch die
heimischen gesundheitsämter haben keine
informationen darüber wer wohin in den
urlaub fährt wer geimpft ist und werden
nach seinem urlaub in quarantäne muss
auch sie können kaum kontrollieren
ungeachtet dieses problems fordert
gesundheitsminister sparen schärfere
einreise regeln und eine testpflicht für
alle die nicht geimpft sind
ob dies allerdings noch vor dem ende der
sommerferien kommt ist unklar
tests pflicht steigen die instanzen all
das wird sicherlich thema sein beim
nächsten treffen der ministerpräsidenten
präsidenten mit der bundeskanzlerin am
10 august und damit früher als geplant
was das impfen gegen korona angeht haben
inzwischen 70 prozent der erwachsenen
mindestens eine spritze bekommen meldet
das bundesgesundheitsministerium
gleichzeitig aber steigen die korona
zahlen weiter an das robert koch
institut registrierte 1545 neue fälle
binnen 24 stunden
362 mehr als vor einer woche 38 menschen
starben im zusammenhang mit kobe 19
die sieben tage instituts steigt auf
14,5 und wir kommen zum nächsten großen
thema derzeit zur flutkatastrophe im
westen deutschlands
noch immer werden dutzende menschen
vermisst das hochwasser ist zwar weg
aber die schäden die bleiben vor allem
die kaputte infrastruktur ist schwer zu
reparieren
getroffen hat es auch ein pflegeheim im
leverkusener stadtteil opladen
dort war die wupper über die ufer
getreten trotz der zerstörungen sind die
bewohnerinnen des heims geblieben
wie gehen sie und das pflegepersonal mit
der situation um
dort ferber hat das heim besucht das
wasser der wupper war hier im keller des
leverkusener seniorenheims nichts geht
mehr rechner telefonanlage
waschmaschinen die zentrale
stromversorgung wurde geflutet jetzt
fehlt es an ersatzteilen knapp zwei
wochen nach dem extremwetter die sachen
müssen natürlich auch besorgt werden und
darin liegt die schwierigkeit also die
firmen sagen das kann durchaus zwei drei
wochen dauern wenn nicht eventuell sogar
länger
die menschen sollen trotzdem in ihrer
gewohnten umgebung bleiben nur ist
vieles ungewohnt
das essen kommt jetzt vom lieferdienst
alles mit plastikgeschirr abwasch
unmöglich notstrom gibt es zwar aber die
notrufanlage funktioniert genauso wenig
wie die aufzüge auch im fünften stock
das personal heute schon wunsch sie
brauchen jetzt mehr personal ohne notruf
ohne telefonanlage pfleger johannes
bliss ist wie einige aus dem team
kurzerhand ins heim gezogen in freie
zimmer auf der korona quarantäne station
sie wollen das hinkriegen gemeinsam auch
wenn es dauern könnte bis hier der
fernseher wieder läuft und die menschen
in den flutgebieten freuen sich über die
große hilfsbereitschaft allein durch die
zdf spendenaktion sind mittlerweile mehr
als 52 millionen euro zusammengekommen
wenn auch sie spenden möchten die iban
des aktionsbündnis katastrophenhilfe
lautet de 65 104 106 100 104 106 100
stichwort zdf hochwasser und weitere
informationen finden sie unter spenden
punkt zdf.de und im zdf text auf seite 8
190 weltweit hin die menschen am
fernseher als diese bilder kamen am
sechsten januar dieses jahres stürmen
radikale anhänger und anhängerinnen des
damaligen us präsidenten donald trump
das capitol mitten im herzen der
hauptstadt washington dc schüsse fallen
fünf menschen sterben an dem tag an dem
die wahl des neuen präsidenten joe biden
bestätigt werden soll
welche rolle hat schon bei diesem
angriff gespielt auch darum geht es seit
heute in einem untersuchungsausschuss
des repräsentantenhauses nina nie war
geil mit den details der vorsitzende
eröffnet die sitzung mit einer warnung
diese videos könnten verstören die
bilder bekannt ein wütender mob der das
kapitel stürmt randalierer die rufen
hängt mike pence
der vizepräsident unter donald trump
bestätigte am 6 januar das wahlergebnis
den wahlsieg joe biden
wie konnte es zu diesen szenen kommen
das wollen die ab
geordneten herausfinden wir lassen uns
allein von den fakten leiten die fakten
über das was am 6 januar passiert ist im
vorfeld dieses tragischen tags und was
seitdem passiert ist vier polizisten
sagen an diesem ersten tag aus einer von
ihnen aqui lino gosnell er war sechster
januar
mittendrin die körperliche gewalt die
wir erlebten wein sätzlich und
verheerend meine kollegen und ich wurden
geschlagen wir wurden getreten mit
chemischen reizstoffen besprüht und
durch augen schädigende laser geblendet
von einem gewalttätigen mob
die polizisten fordern aufklärung wer
verantwortung trägt für das was ihnen
widerfahren ist
doch statt aufklärung gab es in den
vergangenen tagen eine politische
schlammschlacht um die besetzung des
ausschusses die republikaner nominierten
zwei trampler abgeordnete
die demokraten bezeichneten beide als
befangen und lehnten sie ab das wird ein
gescheiterter ausschuss sei ein betrug
den niemand glauben kann
in den kommenden wochen sollen auch
ehemalige mitarbeitende donald trumps
aussagen der trägt nach meinung vieler
die verantwortung für die ereignisse des
sechsten januar das erste mal in der
jüngeren geschichte des vatikans steht
dort seit heute ein kardinal vor gericht
zusammen mit neun weiteren angeklagten
die vorwürfe reichen von korruption über
geldwäsche bis amtsmissbrauch es geht um
einen dubiosen immobiliendeal über mehr
als 350 millionen euro
viel geld wurde dabei verloren auch
einnahmen aus dem peterspfennig der
kollekte eigentlich für wohltätige
zwecke
in deutschland nimmt die
drogenkriminalität seit zehn jahren zu
2020 auch wieder so wurden fast 366.000
rauschgiftdelikte polizeilich erfasst
das sind 1,7 prozent mehr als im vorjahr
bei kokain stieg die zahl um fast 10 bei
christel mesz um gut sieben prozent
einen rückgang gab es bei der partydroge
ecstasy und das wohl weil die klubs in
der pandemie geschlossen waren so die
ermittler innen
grundsätzlich verlagert sich der
rauschgifthandel zunehmend ins internet
deutschland hat neue welterbe stätten
und das nachdem erst am wochenende drei
bedeutende kurorte und das jugendstil
ensemble mathildenhöhe in darmstadt
ausgezeichnet worden waren
jetzt kommt erstmals jüdisches erbe auf
deutschem boden auf die liste der unesco
genau genommen das jüdische erbe von
speyer worms und mainz die sogenannten
schum städte gelten hat eine wege des
europäischen judentums schon ist eine
abkürzung und steht für die
mittelalterlichen hebräischen
anfangsbuchstaben der drei städte
susanne genath berichtet die synagoge in
worms
1034 wurde sie mitten in der stadt
erbaut juden und nicht juden lebten
damals gleichberechtigt zusammen
lange blieb die synagoge erhalten 1938
wurde sie in der reichspogromnacht
zerstört 1961 wieder eröffnet jetzt
gehört sie neben dem friedhof heiliger
sand zum unesco welterbe
er wird der jugend anerkannt und dass es
hat ganz großer bedeutung für diejenige
hierbleiben leben familien gründen und
die gemeinden pflegen
auf dem judenhof in speyer neben der
ehemaligen synagoge die mittelalterliche
mikwe das älteste jüdische frauenbad
deutschlands steine die für jüdisches
leben stehen für vergangenes und
zukünftiges ich hoffe dass dieser unesco
welterbe titel für die shows städten das
judentum auch normal noch bekannter
nacht in seiner vielfalt in seiner
diversität in seiner innovationskraft
und damit eben auch ausstrahlt darauf
dass man merkt judentum ist nichts
separates exotisches gehört zu
deutschland und zu europa seit
jahrhunderten auf dem alten jüdischen
friedhof in mainz stammen die ältesten
grabsteine aus dem elften jahrhundert
hier wurden große gelehrte bestattet bis
heute geachtet und verehrt jüdisches
leben in die weltöffentlichkeit bringen
dazu soll der titel welterbe beitragen
in deutschland bekommt noch einen neuen
unesco welterbetitel anteil des limes
die ehemalige grenze des römischen
reiches
ein überblick über die ausgezeichneten
orte finden sie bei sette erfreute
und in unserer app wieder hat es in
europa extremistische ideen diesmal in
norditalien
dort ist ein hagelsturm übers land
gefegt mit eisbrocken sie so groß waren
wie tennisbälle auf der autobahn bei
parma wurden so hunderte wagen schwer
beschädigt videos zeigen wie der hagel
die windschutzscheibe zertrümmert
zeitweise musste die autobahn gesperrt
werden weil die fahrer auch nach dem
sturm nicht mehr weiterfahren konnten
nun kommen wir zu den ersten beiden
goldmedaillen für deutschland in tokio
arbeite da fangen wir mit dem fast schon
erwartbaren erfolg der dressurreiterin
im teamwettbewerb an die klaren
favoriten haben geliefert mit klarem
abstand auf die konkurrenz der
vierzehnte deutsche olympiasieg in der
mannschaft als letzte starterin geht
jessica von bredow wendel mit ihrer
stute der lehrer in den wettbewerb sie
hat es in der hand nachdem isabell werth
mit belarus und dorothee schneider auf
showtime souverän vorlegen konnten
bredow wandel hält dem druck stand fast
fehlerfrei lenkt sie ihre elegante
tänzerin durch das viereck
es ist eine machtdemonstration der
deutschen dressur equipe am ende stehen
8178 punkte und gold silber im kongress
spezial ging an die usa bronze an
großbritannien
bereits morgen haben die deutschen
reiterinnen im einzelwettbewerb die
nächste chance auf edelmetall in der kür
zählen sie ebenfalls zu den top
favoritinnen
isabell werth könnte gar ihr achtes
olympia gold gewinnen
die erste deutsche goldmedaille holte
ricarda funk im kajak-einer der erste
olympia auftritt der 29 jährigen und der
erste deutsche sieg im kanu slalom der
frauen seit 29 jahren
ricarda funk im ziel die erleichterung
gewaltig 2016 noch die spiele in rio
verpasst heute steht sie ganz oben
olympiasiegerin
wahnsinn ich kann es immer noch kaum
glauben es ist ein traum für mich in
erfüllung gegangen und es ist einfach
sehr real
die 29-jährige ist eine akribische
arbeiterin gilt als perfektionist in im
deutschen team
der tanz auf dem wasser wie sie es einst
nannte gelingt dir heute nahezu perfekt
die favoritin jessica fox aus australien
papst berührt zweimal eine stange
kassiert vier strafsekunden und wird am
ende nur dritter
silber geht an rio siegerinnen show aus
spanien und ricarda funk gewinnt bei
ihrer olympia premiere das erste gold
für deutschland für tischtennis
altmeister timo boll ist der traum von
seiner ersten olympia medaille im einzel
geplatzt
der 40 jahre alte europameister verlor
gegen den südkoreaner jung young sik mit
eins zu vier sätzen
das ist das vierte mal in folge dass
timo boll bei olympia im achtelfinale
gescheitert dagegen hat der deutsche
dimitrij ovtcharov das viertelfinale im
tischtennis einzel erreicht und so gab
es in schwimm- finale über 800 meter
freistil hat es heute doppel weltmeister
florian wellbrock geschafft als
vorlaufzweite haft florieren wellbrock
auf die erste olympische becken medaille
der deutschen schwimmer seit 2008 der
doppel-weltmeister schuld mit 7 41 77
neuen deutschen rekord waren viertes
vorlaufschnellsten hat dem finale am
donnerstag der ukraine
michael romantschuk
auf kurs viertelfinale sind die
deutschen hockey-herren 5 1 gala
vorstellung gegen großbritannien einer
ragt heraus florian fuchs erst der
ausgleich dann sein doppelpack zum
endstand deutschland hinterlässt im
dritten spiel einen ganz starken
eindruck
alexander zverev hat beim tennis weiter
chancen auf zwei medaillen steht nach
dem einzel achtelfinale jetzt im doppel
mit jan lennard struff im viertelfinale
wäre stoff siegen gegen die franzosen
charlie wi fi und treffen jetzt auf die
us-amerikaner craig sind green und mehr
opium sport später bei uns im heute
journal
und zum schluss noch eine gute nachricht
aus australien
dort war hugo 70 jahre lang allein jetzt
endlich hat die galapagos schildkröte
eine freundin gefunden wenn auch vorerst
nur per video treffen die chemie die
scheint aber zu stimmen
estrella heißt die glückliche kommt aus
dem rostocker zoo und muss in australien
nur noch ein paar wochen corona
quarantäne abwarten
der september ist das erste echte runde
wo geplant und natürlich hoffen alle auf
baldigen nachwuchs und wir werden noch
mal kurz ein blick aufs wetter es werden
regen und örtlich unwetter erwartet und
die genauen aussicht gleich ist intelli
für sie das heute journal sehen sie um
21 45 mit bettina schausten
machen sie es gut auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter ja heute gab es ja
wieder heftige gewitter vor allem von
westen her aber morgen werden sie noch
etwas heftiger vor allem im süden
deutschlands das liegt an diesem tief
hier das schiebt hier feucht kalte
luftmassen zu uns und dementsprechend
lösen die gewitter aus und das -tief
gehört außerdem zu einem konglomerat von
mehreren tiefs hat sich hier festgesetzt
das wechselhafte wetter setzt sich
mindestens bis zum wochenende noch fort
schauen wir auf die nacht da ziehen sich
die schauer und gewitter in den süden
zurück im norden lassen die schauer
ebenfalls nach und die temperaturen
sinken auf 12 grad im hessischen
bergland und 18 grad an der ostsee ja
und morgen vor allem in der nordhälfte
immer wieder schauer besonders richtung
nord sie auch heftige schauer und
gewitter und im süden ebenfalls vor
allem an den alpen ziehen ihre kräftige
gewitter ostwärts und bringen starkregen
und hagel mit die sind wieder im
unwetter bereich und die temperaturen
erreichen höchstwerte von 27 grad im
osten und 20 grad an den alpen die
nächsten tage am donnerstag geht es
relativ ruhig durch den tag bis 28 grad
aber am freitag dann im süden gewitter
und auch am samstag unbeständig ein
schöner abend